bonjour à tous bienvenue sur facebook
lite france 3 centre val de loire nous
sommes en direct ici en indre-et-loire
du domaine de candé dans le petit
village de mons dans une ambiance vous
l'avez vu un champêtre très agréable
pour cette nouvelle édition 2010 est du
festival terres du son il y aura
beaucoup d'artistes qui vont passer sur
ce facebook live jusqu'à dimanche et on
va commencer avec un premier qui sera
justement sur scène dans quelques heures
vers 17h45 aujourd'hui cet été merci
d'être avec nous ce midi il fait chaud
hein c'est agréable comme cette cette
ambiance vous allez mettre le feu sur
scène je me questionne peuple quand j'ai
préparé cette interview je me suis dit
peut signifier votre prénom tt parce que
souvent on doit vous poser cette
question c'est un prénom compte pas
souvent ici c'est mon vrai prénom c'est
un prénom qui m'a été donné en hommage à
mon parrain à l'époque ça pas de
signification particulière
mais quand je vais commencer à chanter
en fait j'avais toujours joué dans des
groupes
et puis cerise est pas d'imagination
j'ai choisi de garder mon prénom
d'accord parce que moi j'avais trouvé
sur sur sur internet en faisant quelques
recherches que ça signifiait le deed
parce que c'est un peu ça alors ça c'est
un truc que j'ai regardé une fois je
suis parti en vacances au sénégal il ya
un titre qui voulait me vendre un
souvenir qui m'a dit que mon prénom
voulait dire ça mais je pense qu'en fait
il essaie surtout de me dire ce qu'ils
pensaient que je voulais entendre pour
vendre son souvenir donc fait que
finalement j'ai pas acheté
mais l'anecdote est resté quoi qu'il en
soit qu'est-ce qui vous guide vous dans
la vie moi ce qui me guide dans la vie
c'est l'amour des musique acoustique
folk blues soul c'est les histoires
c'est particulièrement sur cette tournée
la revenir à une échelle plus simple des
choses pour avoir un rapport plus simple
encore une fois au plaisir alors c'est
sûr que là on s'est un petit peu
exceptionnelle en à la terre de son mais
toute cette année on a privilégié
vraiment des lieux intimistes pour
pouvoir vraiment faire des concerts ce
qu'elle appelle à hauteur d'yeux sac en
général quand on sort un concert il y a
musiciens qui sont sur scène et des gens
qui en contrebas voilà et c'est ça et
c'est vrai qu'on a vraiment essayé de
faire le contrepoint à ça cette année
d'une parce que ça va avec
l'histoire de mon nouvel album qui met
en scène un personnage qui essaient de
se réinventer
confronté à une époque qui comprend plus
et puis moi c'était aussi une manière de
reconnecter avec l'endroit d'où je viens
j'ai commencé à jouer aux terrasses des
cafés il ya 15 20 ans faisant de chapeau
moi je n'en avais pas joué dans les bars
dans la rue c'est un peu comme ça que je
me suis fait là à la main on va dire et
c'est vrai que c'est vital pour moi de
garder le contact avec ce à quoi on va
parler de votre dernière réponse dans
quelques instants avant cela on va
redonner un petit coup sûr votre enfance
parce que lorsque vous étiez petit
première action que vous avez touché
c'est le violon et c'est à cause ou
plutôt on va dire grâce à un accident de
la vie que vous avez découvert la
guitare que si tu passais en fait pour
que vous puissiez tombé amoureux de
cette guitare vers l'âge de 16 ans je me
suis cassé la jambe donc convalescence
un mois de plâtre juste avant mon
anniversaire et j'hésite entre un
appareil photo une guitare je faisais la
guitare et à l'époque c'était vraiment
l'idée de se faire plaisir soit et puis
ces voix-là de fil en fil fin de fil en
aiguille on veut que les copains qui
vous invite à jouer dans un groupe épi
qui vous encouragent à essayer de 2,2
chanter de d'aller contre sa timidité et
puis de d'aller raconter des histoires
comme ça tout ça s'est fait très
progressivement mais fois que le fil
rouge c'est vraiment été le plaisir en
fait beaucoup plus à cette guitare
aujourd'hui puisqu'elle vous apporte
voilà et jouer de la guitare
enfin jouer d'un instrument c'est une
espèce de passeport vers l'ailleurs que
vous avez tout le temps sur vous c'est
une amie
c'est une sorte de baromètre parce que
quand vous
on dit souvent que les gens qui élèvent
des bêtes on est mon image avec blizzard
mais les gens qui élèvent des baies tous
les gens qui ont des chevaux ne partent
jamais en vacances parce qu'on peut pas
laisser son jeu passe dans le pré comme
ça va partir et revenir trois semaines
et sa tendresse que rien ne rien n'est
changé mais une guitare c'est un peu
pareil c'est un baromètre par rapport à
l'amour que vous donnez à votre passion
si vous si vous touchez plus votre
guitare pendant trois semaines quand
vous voulez voir les reprenez vous le
fait sentir mais il ya vraiment un
rapport d'artisanat par rapport à ça qui
moi me porte depuis fou depuis 25 30 ans
et ça que ça voilà c'est un plaisir de
pouvoir continuer continue au jour le
jour à d'une même passion plaisir à la
voir avec vous notamment dans votre
dernier album qui s'intitule les
chroniques de pierrot qui est sorti il
ya quelques mois qui est ce qui re
lunaire alors c'est aux pierrots
lunaires c'est un personnage qui est
confronté à une violence du monde tel
qu'on le connaît actuellement une
violence qu'il n'aurait plus à
comprendre et ils arrivent à la
conclusion que la solution c'est
peut-être d'essayer de changer le regard
qu'ils portent sur ce monde
à défaut de pouvoir changer ce monde et
du coup il va partir de chanson en
chanson
essayez d'aller réinventer son regard un
peu comme on est condamnés à nous
réinventer en tant que citoyen en tant
que consommateur tant que producteur en
ce moment donc en quelque sorte y
partage ses états d'âme
je dirais qu'en fait pire les nerfs ça
raconte en creux nos destinée collective
encore une fois on est tous un petit peu
engagés sur une voie donc on sait pas
bien où elle nous mène et on est tous
encore une fois condamné à trouver des
solutions de 2,2 de commandes du vivre
ensemble comment relever les défis qui
s'imposent à nous les défis
environnementaux les défis sociétaux les
défis économiques parce que le monde
qu'on a connu nenê n'est plus mais en
même temps si une espèce de nouveau far
west qui est fascinant parce que tout le
monde peut apporter sa pierre et essayer
de battre changer le monde comme on dit
quoi vous vous essayez de changer le
monde à votre manière ce sont finalement
des causes qui vous tiennent à coeur que
vous partagez le travers de ce
personnage mais je crois qu'en fait ce
qui filtre ladesou c'est qu'on a tous
commandé aucun homme n'est une île on a
tous une famille des amis
des enfants tous impacté par ça on
essaie de faire attention à ce qu'on
mange on essaie de faire attention
d'autres manières de consommer à ce que
chacun savait pas et maintenant on sait
que quand on achète une paire de baskets
il ya forcément un moment donné ou à un
autre va se retrouver à flotter
indéfiniment dans dans l'océan peut plus
faire comme si on savait pas et puis je
crois que c'est le monde qu'on va
laisser à nos enfants
c'est bon vous parler des enfants une
chanson vous raconter comment finalement
en tant qu'adulte on perd son âme
d'enfant
qu'avez vous gardez vous de votre
enfance parce que j'espère avoir gardé
me demande donc de mon enfance et cette
capacité à s'émerveiller
cette capacité à avoir envie c'est que
le propre d'un enfant c'est quand il
veut entre qu'il le veut tout de suite
et c'est impérieux kom kom kom kom kom
déjà mais je crois encore une fois c'est
comme ça qu'on change les choses avec
cette espèce d'énergie comme ça et c'est
vrai que je crois que la passion c'est
ce qui est le plus proche de cette magie
de l'enfance et qu'on arrive à garder
comme ça toute une vie quand on regarde
son sa magie de l'enfance finalement ne
vieillit pas vieillir c'est bien parce
qu'on
on saisit la valeur des choses moi ça
fait quinze vingt ans que je fais ça
j'ai déjà joué à terre de son mais il ya
sept ans et je pense que quand j'ai
commencé ce métier non je ne me rendais
pas compte de la chance que j'avais de
commencer un jour d'instruments dans sa
chambre et puis qu'est des gens qui
acceptent de fédérer leurs énergies leur
temps autour de sa passion et je sais
maintenant de prix que ça parce que
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de
collègues qui jouait régulièrement
comment j'ai commencé et qu'on pût la
chance de faire ce métier là donc je
sais qu'un jour comme aujourd'hui c'est
précieux ça exceptionnel ça n'arrive pas
tous les tous les jours et ça c'est vrai
que c'est l'âge qui m'a apporté ce recul
la cua mais qu'est ce que vous appréciez
particulièrement ici à terre du sang
parce que effectivement vous êtes venus
en 2010 parce que j'apprécie dentaire de
son c'est que moi j'ai commencé à jouer
enfin à tourner comme on dit à faire des
concerts et des tourangeaux et des gens
d'orléans
ce qui fait qu'en fait ces festivals là
c'est la face immergée de tout le site
de tissu associatif d'une région et
c'est des gens avec qui moi j'ai
commencé il ya 15 20 ans et je sais que
c'est des gens qui maquille comme moi
soit on est mû par leur passion et c'est
beau quand on a la passion là elle prend
elle prend exactement
exactement c'est que c'est que c'est je
crois qu'on est quoi sur vingt mille
personnes par jour je sais pas donc
c'est vrai que c'est des chiffres assez
colossaux qui donne qui donne le tournis
c'est beau de se dire que tout ça a
commencé avec une petite graine et que
c'est vraiment représentatif d'un vrai
truc d'une vraie identité de région des
milliers personnes qui vont écouter
votre dernier album qui marque comme
votre retour aux sources avec un savant
mélange de blues et de folk
ce sont deux styles finalement dans
lesquels vous vous sentez le mieux
exactement je crois que j'ai eu la
chance de voyager beaucoup d'être d'être
au contact de beaucoup de musiques
différentes mais on parlait tout à
l'heure de la magie de l'enfance je
crois qu'il ya on a beau être curieux
dans la vie il ya souvent qu'un ou deux
trucs dans la vie qui vous donne des
petits papillons dans le ventre
et c'est vrai qu'en musique on a souvent
tendance à intellectualiser en disant
c'est intéressant alors qu'en fait ça va
pas être intéressant ça doit vous ça va
vous faire un trou nous chatouiller ça
vous chatouille et ça doit vous quand
j'étais quand on était bon on n'avait
pas les mots mais c'est là que c'était
bon en général c'est quand on savait pas
comment le décrire c'est c'était là
puisque vous parlez des mots justement
tu ne peux pas décrire pour vous mais
aussi pour d'autres artistes alors
notamment frérot de la ligue avec ton
visage pourquoi finalement ne pas avoir
gardé ce morceau pour vous ah parce que
c'est ce sont les frères da veiga qu'on
écrit la musique en fête
et puis un jour ils m'ont ils m'ont
proposé en fait d'écrire des paroles
dessus donc on se rencontrait on a
discuté pendant une petite demi heure
pour que j'ai c'est un petit peu de
cerner autant que possible en si peu de
temps
leur personnalité ils m'ont raconté une
très belle histoire l'attachement je
parlais de région tout à l'heure à la
région c'est des gens du littoral
arcachon de la dune du pilat il disait
que c'est vraiment très reconnaissant
parce que la ville rapporte m et que
chaque fois qu'ils aient quitté leur
région pour aller faire des concerts
c'est toujours d'une espèce
d'arrachement d'équité la mer leurs amis
leur famille et c'est comme ça que m'est
venue cette idée là ton ton visage quoi
et puis ensuite ils ont donc fait la
chanson la chanson que c'est devenu et
je crois que encore une fois c'est la
magie de se laisser porter par les
accidents comme le fait de se casser une
jambe avant de commencer à jouer de la
guitare sans se douter de bac ça va
devenir ma vie plus tard je trouve c'est
ce qui peut vous arriver de plus beau
dans la vie en fait cette petite perte
de contrôle à la magie des accidents
puisse laisser porter comme ça le
partage avec les autres hein parce que
en 2012 dont vous avez fait un duo avec
imany un gospel pour madame qui sera
aussi d'ailleurs un terreau du son on la
verra dimanche sur scène
que vous apporte ses duos comme ça il ya
une ambiance complètement différente
vous êtes très souvent en solo ouais
en fait c'est une porte d'entrée
différentes sur ce métier là c'est un
peu je sais que j'ai tout le temps des
images un peu étrange mais quand on fait
des pâtes en général on fait les pattes
comme nos parents l'évier et il suffit d
fois d'aller manger des amis il se rend
compte qu'on peut faire manger des pâtes
avec 20 des pâtes au sarrasin des pâtes
au blé des pâtes des pâtes sans gluten
pas dans mon milieu une manière de et
c'est vrai que c'est au détour de votre
foi d'un rien d'une petite voix là dans
un petit moment partagé comme ça et
spaghettis qu'on a dans les aristochats
en fait c'est ça mais excellent mais
c'est exactement ça et c'est vrai que
c'est une autre porte d'entrée et c'est
vrai que les questions que je suis amené
à me poser en fait quand j'essayais
d'écrire pour quelqu'un d'autre
c'est un peu comme quelqu'un qui fait de
la cordonnerie faire dd du sur mesure
c'est une chose de très noble et on est
vraiment juste se poser avec la personne
pour qui on confectionne une paire de
chaussures ou un objet nobles comme ça
parce qu'on est moins patrimoine et et
c'est vrai que du coup on revient à ses
propres chansons par une autre porte et
en se posant d'autres questions et ça
fait grandir
merci d'avoir été avec nous tu étais en
direct sur ce facebook lite france 3
centre val de loire on va se retrouver
un peu plus tard en fin de journée avec
le groupe naïve new beaters et puis
également synapses une dernière question
justement est ce que vous vous aimez la
musique électro j'aime beaucoup la
musique électro moi je vous parlais
justement des passerelles qui assez
souvent les petites amies les
passerelles et puis voilà moi à l'époque
ya très longtemps j'ai une petite amie
qu'écouter de la musique électro donc je
me suis je me suis intéressé mais c'est
surtout qu'en fait je crois que la
musique électro aller partout maintenant
même les gens qui font de la musique à
guitare comme ce qui est mon cas c'est
bien souvent des programmations qui a
derrière et puis à l'époque qu'à changer
un petit peu tout ça donc je crois que
la musique électro elle est omniprésente
quoi c'est qu'un jour on aura un
featuring avec un dj dans l'un de vos
albums
ben pourquoi pas ça me fait penser un
peu à vide gisti qu'on connaît tous au
brevet est en fait il a remixé une
chanson d'un héros en fête de la musique
à guitare donc voilà c'est quand les
mondes se rencontrent comme ça c'est là
où ça donne des plus belles choses
rendez vous est pris on verra ça
peut-être dans quelques mois voilà on se
retrouve un peu plus tard en facebook
live sur france 3 centre val de loire
dont va profiter évidemment de la météo
parce qu'il fait quand même très chaud
ici vers site était d'avoir été avec
nous a très vite